Do you think Jeffrey Epstein killed himself? No,
I think he was killed by that guy. That, that, that, that guy,
that they put in a cell that Luna tech, uh, who's that big muscled guy.
I think he was just, he did it for money.
Kept his mouth shut that's money from whom do you think Massaad?
Am I six CIA or three?
So there's a lot of pressure from a lot of different profitably,
probably massaged CIA more. I mean,
it seems clear that he was working inside of a honeypot intelligence operation,
just land Maxwell's father was in Israeli, super spy, uh,
just lame Maxwell's working for Israeli intelligence. It would be odd to think.
And of course the CIA knows about everything that Israeli intelligence is doing
with Americans. So, uh, I would think that, uh,
it's a very cozy relationship with those two intelligence agencies. And, uh,
I think if you ran it by anyone, I think if you ran it by French intelligence,
they'd go, yeah, no, get, get it up.
I don't think there was any intelligence service in the world whose job was to
protect the powerful people that live in their countries that was against him
getting whacked.
But do you think it's possible that he's just an evil person who is after
manipulating people and also was it well, so that there's a bigger thing,
factual, that there's a bigger thing. Evil people don't get has a, your facts,
Tim Dylan. No, there's no facts of the case you don't get. That is 65.
Show me another evil guy who was handed a $65 million, uh, uh,
place by Les Wexner.
Show me another evil guy that got that type of a handshake deal,
where he was basically, uh, let off without anything.
After a judge had made a very sweetheart deal for him after he
was accused of molesting a 14 year old, show me another evil guy that,
uh, doesn't have that kind of backing that has those types of friends,
those connections, those type of properties. Show me, uh, you know,
multiple passports all over the world.
So show me a guy without anyone backing him, that's doing it. Why didn't they,
you know, you think he's just a,
an evil guys who was doing this for whom it's his own, just and giggles.
He's just got it. Hang off on it. Human nature, human nature. Huh?
It's human nature. Right? $70 million, uh, limestone man. Yeah.
Is it human nature? And it's, I don't think it's human nature. I think it's,
I think it's, I think they manipulated human nature, but I think they,
I think they did it. I think just laying back,
I think Epstein was really just a functionary and I think just lane was kind of
a pimp and Epstein was kind of a guy that, you know, made the money. Okay. And,
you know, hid money and things like that.
And worked for a lot of powerful people.
I don't believe in lone pedophiles anymore.
I don't even believe that if you're a pedophile you're like in a group,
you know what I mean?